what's up guys welcome to ij likes now
this is a special episode because i am
not at my house i'm actually in new york
for the youtube music awards and i'm
super excited they are the sunday can
you guys just check out my fox sweater
because i'm really excited about it ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
so the youtube music awards happening on
november 3rd at six o'clock eastern so
you guys can watch on youtube.com
youtube but most importantly until then
you guys can vote for your favorite
artist in any of the categories it's
actually pretty easy all you have to do
is share the official nominee video on g
plus on twitter on facebook and places
that you guys like to share your videos
since we're on the topic of music this
video i about
i i don't know like it actually almost
made me cry it's an emotional baby
crying because of the mothers we're not
missing you
wake up missing you
when the one you know god it's like the
cutest thing ever and i don't even like
babies but i do like puppies so here's
some dogs singing
play
that's the performance of a lifetime
thing
good girl now onto some tech and gaming
news i'm pretty excited because the
first sign of new consoles has arrived
at my doorstep i received my playstation
4 controller of which i proceeded to
destroy the unboxing a bunch of other
people said that they have spotted some
games some controllers in the
playstation 4 camera in game stops so
guess what that means it's almost time
the ps4 will be out november 15th and
the xbox one which i am super excited
about will be out on november 22nd so
basically you guys may never see me
again unless you're on my gaming channel
you wanna say hi to youtube
this is my new friend tom we're like
best friends now
besties we have a secret band that we
started but we can't tell you about it
yeah totally top secret right now yeah
it's top secret
also big gaming news assassin's creed
black flag is now out and i've actually
just been watching gameplay because i
didn't travel with my xbox on this trip
so i'm excited to go home and play but
i'm even more excited for november 5th
because as you guys
already know that's my favorite game
call of duty ghosts is coming out
i can't come soon enough first i
probably should fix my hair also i
should probably note that it's halloween
today and unless you're watching this
tomorrow it's probably not halloween so
happy halloween let me know what you
guys are gonna be for halloween send me
some pics i was batman in a onesie so
obviously
i was very comfy moving right along to
ij book club
i am pretty excited because i downloaded
melissa explains it all so back in the
day melissa jonehart had a show called
clarissa explains it all and i used to
be obsessed she now has book out and
obviously i'm not going to read it
because i'm going to have it be read to
me with my fantastic audible let me know
what book you guys get using audible.com
ijustine you get a free book you get a
free trial by now you guys should
probably know the drill there's a link
in the description so i got to do is
click it and it'll take you to do the
rest that's it for this episode of ij
likes here from new york stay tuned
because i'm going to be doing a lot of
fun stuff this week with youtube and the
youtube music awards i believe would be
hosting the red carpet with style haul
so check them out on twitter and
facebook and instagram and youtube
because they will probably be posting
videos and photos before i will even get
a chance to let me know if you guys have
any questions that you would like me to
ask people on the red carpet if there's
a certain musician or certain youtuber
that you would like me to find to
interview leave them in the comments i
will see you guys later i gotta go
do some some secret stuff
you